hey i'm dr keller have you ever had a  champagne hangover they can be pretty  brutal and there's a reason for it see  the bubbles in champagne actually make  the alcohol get into your bloodstream  faster and literally it goes straight to  your head so if you're looking to avoid  a hangover then you should avoid  carbonated beverages that include  champagne and also carbonated mixers  that you're mixing with your alcohol now  if you're in an event where you have to  have a glass of champagne to toast the  bride and groom then have that glass and  then switch to something that's  uncarbonated like white wine or a vodka  i promise you you'll feel much better in  the morning  i'm dr keller there's a hangover tip for  you  you